je m'appelle ratio Pierre
né à Tours en juillet 1901 mon père
était d'une heure de long Haute-Garonne
et ma mère était de la Vienne tu vois
j'ai commencé à prendre
du désert
on peut pas dire c'est bien on peut pas
le comparer on peut comparer à rien
[Musique]
il faut un sentiment qui vous guide
votre travail ainsi on dit quelle
chanson aimez-vous souvent on m'a
demandé ça mais toujours ce genre ça
correspond pas avec qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent mettre avec un chiffre si par
exemple je dis ah non ça va pas il faut
que j'ai une chanson sentimentale vous
êtes aussi jolie on mélange blonde que
vos rêves amoureux
etc
sur les flots
[Musique]
pour faire attention
le modèle après tout il vient pour l'art
il vient
l'amour c'est une autre chose
pour mettre le sapeur sur les rails et
ben voilà il faudrait avoir que des
niçoise pour se faire faire leur tête à
ce moment-là vous verriez toute la
chambre de députés viendrait me faire
faire leur tête il serait immortalisé il
faudrait aussi surtout le Georges ah si
Georges se faisait faire la tête on
aurait tous les types au banderoles et
puis alors vous verrez comment que ça
irait il y a alors voilà la statuaire
serait sur les rails et il y aurait plus
qu'à rouler
de tes yeux ta bouche pour tout respire
l'amour mystérieux
tes lèvres sont les roses que l'on
voudrait cueillir
le soir à deux
on les voit on les voit sans trop rire
tourner carrément là encore
[Musique]
un jeune homme dans les griffes mine de
rien elle les mène où elles veulent donc
elles sont des simulatrices les
provocatrices
voilà voilà
[Musique]
quelque chose pour ce but dedans alors
là oui alors parlez-moi des positions
universelle
il faudrait être bien avec le bon Dieu
ou avec le diable
[Musique]